they turned out in their thousands
despite this rally being banned young
and old even children were there they
weren't going to stop demanding
democracy but there was evident anger
and frustration a billboard marking the
70th anniversary of communist rule in
China was ripped down and all along the
way they sprayed graffiti and it didn't
take long for that to happen
this is the seat of the Hong Kong
government there's a lot of anger over
how the authorities have handled this
and this is the 13th consecutive week of
protests with them getting ever more
violent the water cannon used this time
had blue dye to stain protesters who
could be picked up later the protesters
and more and more determined and more
and more angry
the protesters handed out rocks to throw
at the police we saw them using
catapults to aim marbles and they threw
back gas canisters fired in their
direction as well as lobbed petrol bombs
streets in the heart of this one of the
world's leading financial hubs were shut
down as astonished tourists and shoppers
looked on aghast at the scenes unfolding
in front of them time and again the
protesters were able to outwit the
police at one stage building and setting
a light a large barricade around the
corner from the police headquarters
[Music]
quite difficult to believe extremely
difficult
the authorities struggled to bring the
situation under control as pictures of
Hong Kong burning swept around the world
in this video we were given protesters
claimed the men in black are undercover
police officers mingling with
demonstrators and protesters say two
live rounds were fired into the air
claims we can't verify then the riot
police led by a small contingent of
British officers moved in on us and they
were determined to make some arrests
this is what many protesters fear most
with repeated claims of police brutality
and sexual violence against the women
once they're out of sight of witnesses
[Music]
are you getting control of the streets
at this stage no they weren't so they
went on the offensive and as protesters
headed for a train station this happens
the sight of young people cowering
begging not to be hit by police is not a
good look for Hong Kong this was a very
black day for Hong Kong and the violence
is escalating on both sides with no end
in sight and the situation getting more
and more out of control
Alex Crawford Sky News Hong Kong